HR I got a question for you can you make
a pitching change without going to the
mound can a manager do that well I could
being forced on him now I think but I
don't want to give up I don't want to
give up a trip to the mound can I just
walk out and yell to my catcher just say
to the umpire or can I point to my arm
to bring in the right-hander so I don't
waste a visit to the mound no once once
you make a pitching change that
constitutes a visit to the mound see
what a Major League Baseball say about
this Major League Baseball says that it
does not count as a mound of is mound
visits are counted when a pitcher is not
removed from the game hmm what do you
think about that here when a pitcher is
not removed from the game counts as a
mound visit that right first remove if
you remove yeah I think they're saying
that knowingly that if you remove a guy
from the game he has been well here's
why you would might say hey I'm sorry I
still think it's a mouth is that if you
remove the pitcher okay but if I do a
double switch does that constitute a
mound visit during an inning yes because
if you're double if you double switch
them with the pitcher in a new position
its counts as I move and therefore the
move is counting that this is about time
Dan we're talking about the time of play
I know alright let's let's guess what
Harold is eating Pauly you go first our
side thinks it's an apple okay an apple
fritzy some kind of granola and
nutrition bar or some sort of Seaton I'm
gonna say gum gum I'm gonna go ice cube
well actually it was all right you're
like pink at the Super Bowl with the
anthem you know just take the gum out
the gum out and then put it back in when
you're done well I already did and
you're so good that you actually even
caught that I had gum in myself most
people wouldn't do that no that's good
oh yeah thank you thank you that leads
me to this point of the day when Freddie
and fellows left when I first was
hanging out with Dan patcher here and I
was asked how do you do interviews and
he said the number one thing is listen
you have to listen to the person you're
talking to I've never forgot it's the
greatest advice ever had yeah and not
enough people do that because there's
something that's said and then you
follow up on and I always I think people
get into this kind of routine when they
go okay
I'm gonna ask these questions and these
in this order and somebody may have just
said something
and then you just blow right by it so
I'm glad you remember that Harold thank
you I was listening I had this piece of
play what is this gonna mean for the
viewer well I think I don't know I mean
we're still up in the air with all these
things that are gonna happen we'll see
adjustments along the way but I think
the one immediate impact that will
happen is that what the Commissioner is
trying to do is speed the game up and
since there's not as much action with
double plays guys stealing first a third
first a home double hit-and-run
different things like that he's forced
an action when there's not action in the
game then there's too much dead time so
I think he's trying to eliminate that
dead time and get the ball moving so
you're gonna notice that right away I
think secondly you will notice the
catcher not going out three and four
times before there's a pitch thrown
because they have a conversation at the
mouth so I think there's gonna be a
combination of things it's gonna be the
biggest impact I think will happen
probably from the seventh inning on
because what happens if you waste your
visits early you gotta have to
strategically figure out I got to use
those later with all the pitching
changes that are made do you like these
changes
I like what he's trying to do and I
think time will tell
I was the one that was for the pitch
count the pitch clock to be honest I
really thought that would be a bigger
change than what we're going to see with
with the mound business right now
I think the pitch clock is coming unless
the players can actually show that games
can speed up but then you can't have
every one third of the at-bats resulting
with the strikeout yeah you know and and
when you have that going on in baseball
you got to create action every sport has
made rule changes even your favorite
sport and basketball you change the
rules to get points we see it in
football baseball has got to get the
ball in play and run scored and you got
to change rules yeah and that's my
biggest problem with this with pace of
play I don't care if a game is four
hours long if there's movement there but
even something as simple as runner on
second base move him over to third at
least there's movement there now it's on
either gonna strike you out you're gonna
try to hit a home run and that that's my
bigger issue with Major League Baseball
is it's become all or nothing
type of sport and therefore you don't
have movement
therefore it feels like it drags on and
then you're just you're setting up these
pitching changes because who nobody goes
nine innings anymore rarely do you go
eight and even seven feels like a
stretch therefore you're gonna have all
these mound visits and then the call to
the bullpen and the commercial inventory
those are the things that slow down the
game and those are the issues that I
have with this you're dead on I mean
that's the hole at the end of the day
when we put it all into a ball you've
nailed it the action has to happen and
that is what's going on when you result
with the walk a home run and a strikeout
those are the three two outcomes that we
now have with every general manager in
baseball trying to get and when
everybody's playing the same style of
game yeah you get the result of what
we're getting we're starting to get more
athletes back in the game now where you
the beauty of baseball before people
just say that the triple is the greatest
play because you watch the guy run you
see everything
you know so we need to get back to
seeing that see somebody make a great
throw see somebody be able to make a
great tag a guy run all those things
come in on one play now we're watching a
catcher and a pitcher like catch with
guys swinging a missile yeah there's
only three people at in inaction the
pitcher catcher in the hitter it feels
like on you know preponderance of
pitches there we're talking to Harold
Reynolds Major League Baseball Network
analyst you're good friends with with
Alex Rodriguez Alex getting closer to
maybe popping the question to JLo I knew
that was coming
I I don't know that tell you what I'm
shocked that they haven't known each
other or met each other early in their
lives they are almost like clones
they're the same person it's like
Michael and Janet Jackson I mean they
complete each other's sentences they
really are so much alike it's amazing to
me who's better-looking what it's close
its close give me the story that we
should keep an eye on in spring training
you know everybody's talking about the
Yankees and judge and Stan which is a
great story for me it's Joe Hale Donny
I'm sorry that's the story of baseball I
want to see him pitch I want to see him
hit and I'd love to see him do it in the
same game and see what happens how good
is he be you know it it's word of mouth
and oh my gosh this guy is going to be
the next Babe Ruth well he's not going
to be the next Babe Ruth but what are
reasonable expectations as a pitcher and
a hitter for him well I think the one
proven is the pitching side we've
watched that with with a lot of the
Japanese aces that come over and there
are as advertised the pitching is legit
I think he'll blow people away the
offense is the question because we
really haven't had a guy outside of
Matsui so to speak that's had the power
but Ichiro
I remember Ichiro his first spring
training Lou Piniella was like who is
this guy
he quickly found out that Ichiro get
here yeah he goes to sixty two heads you
know so I don't know it's Joe Hale
Donnie's gonna do I mean you watch a guy
take batter price you go I don't know
and they might just show up in the game
and he's Thunder balls so that to me is
the most intriguing part of the story
can he hit cuz I'm convinced he's gonna
be able to pitch each Rose a
hall-of-famer inning no doubt first
ballot for me okay and how about you
yeah yeah I mean it wasn't a winner
yeah yeah yeah yeah I think he was a
great outfielder on-base percentage not
as high as I would want in that you know
leadoff spot but you know he was a Rod
Carew type guy and had a great arm just
he didn't win I don't know if he was I
think he was a great player I don't know
if he was a you know there was any
leadership I don't think there was any
other quality that went with him I don't
know if that factors in but as far as a
great hitter I'd put him up there with
you know Rod Carew and Boggs and Gwynn
with his ability to you know flip the
bat yeah you know from that style no
doubt about it though that will come
along and he's fantastic yeah yeah
alright first man all right we'll put
him in there but you know how these
voters are they may not put him in first
ballot you never know define what a
hall-of-famer is but we'll see all right
hey we'll talk to you down the road
thanks for joining us as always VP is
the greatest curveball at Mets top man
right I'll talk to you later about that
okay see I told Fritchie to tell you
that did I tell you to great Thank You
Man
thank you yeah I've Fritzing didn't I
say to say to Harold just asking I don't
want you talking about to dry a little
bit okay what is the official answer do
I have to go to the mound to make a
pitching change the question I posed to
Major League Baseball was can a manager
remove a pitcher without physically
going to the mound to take him out and
the response was that doesn't count as a
mound visit mound visits are counted
when a pitcher is not removed from the
game
yeah but can I still replace do I have
to go to the mound is the question they
didn't answer that they just said it's
not a mound visit I can I can see if I
can get more information I guess that
point was it's a moot point about as far
as the six per nine innings that somehow
they responded to it Yesi man this like
all of a sudden this six mound visit
thing just got a lot lamer then it's
like you could still take your picture
out six times and visit each of them
once that actually to me that means
there's 12 mound visits now I'm confused
I know less than I did yes play what if
you used semantics you go to change your
pitcher and then you talk to him then
you change your mind and you didn't
actually take him out of the game can
you that count as a pitching change it's
mail that I have no idea a lot of point
I have no idea by the way
Harold Reynolds appearance brought to
you by mercedes-benz drivers seat the
2018 mercedes-benz e-class with a suite
of innovative technologies it's one of
the most intelligent cars on the road go
to MBUSA dot-com and that sounds like a
badass car there yeah that thing's
moving yeah visit your local dealership
to schedule your test drive today for
more Dan Patrick show to the audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV or download the
Dan Patrick show app
you